[Music]
you're not peter parker i am so confused
right now
that valve that you bought started
pulling in visitors from every universe
the multiverse is real
they all die fighting spider-man there
has to be another way there isn't
they're a danger to our universe
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
spiderman no way home in theaters
december 17th what's happening they're
starting to come through and i can't
stop them when you're thinking i'm about
to do something that could break the
universe i know you run it by us
we need to send them
back you're not going to take this away
from me
you're flying out into the darkness to
fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting spider-man i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another win there is it
spiderman no way home december 17th i
underestimated you peter do i know you
looks like we got competition
we started getting some visitors
in their universe they all die fighting
spider-man
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another win there isn't
what's happening they're starting to
come through i can't stop him
spider-man no way home exclusively on
movie theaters december 17th ever since
i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal that was when you found out
peter
that spell that you botched it started
pulling in visitors from every universe
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop him
spider-man no way home you're thinking
hey i'm about to do something that could
break the universe run it by us next
time in theaters december 17.
this is peter leave a message yeah peter
this is happy
who are those guys huh
multiverse is
real that a dinosaur
in theaters december 17th
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life is felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby doo this crap you know all
this is kind of your mess i know a
couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spiderman
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
you
[Music]